this is gotham
the city breeds a special class of criminal
people die here
people like us
Welcome back everyone let's put a smile on that
bass this is going to be my titan season 3 trailer
we have batman all over the place we have joker
there's so many easter eggs going on here so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there's so much batman and big dc stuff that's
going to be happening later this year especially
because we have so many versions of batman flying
around we have the robert pattinson batman and
matt reeves batman movie next year we have ben
affleck batman coming back in the flash movie
and we have michael keaton's batman also coming
back for the flash movie in fact they just dropped
a teaser for michael keaton's batman i did a video
for that a little while ago but the major new
characters that they have coming to titan season
3 that they've already announced all appear in
the trailer footage here so obviously the biggest
being joker i was not expecting him they didn't
say much about him before this but because we
have red hood you kind of need joker to explain
how jason todd becomes red hood we do witness
their version of batman of death in the family in
batman under the red hood although those are two
completely different stories in the comics i guess
they're kind of combining those to explain how
this version of jason todd becomes red hood but
their batman is back obviously sir jorah mormont
batman from game of thrones played by ian glenn
he's like the 50-something age batman so like
a solid 10 years or so older than ben affleck's
batman he's already parted ways with dick grayson
a long time ago before the events of season one
we just got done watching him become nightwing
and get his new costume at the end of season two
and i believe that batman is also supposed to
be taking on their version of tim drake i think
that they're gonna do tim drake this season or a
version of tim drake because he is the next robin
that batman takes on after jason todd was believed
to have died during the events of death in the
family batman found his body so at least when that
story was first published he really did die jason
todd was dead they buried him and put him in the
ground but if he didn't read all the other comics
that sort of went hand in hand with batman under
the red hood to explain how he came back to life
jim lee was the one that started that during
batman hush so he just teased the idea that jason
todd might be alive but he didn't actually bring
him back it was just this big trick of hush and
then his body just goes missing like jason todd's
body goes missing from his grave at the end of the
story they didn't actually bring him back till
after infinite crisis and it was because of what
super boy prime was doing with alexander luther
during that he comes back to life but then talia
al-ghul finds him he's all confused he doesn't
have his memories so she actually restores him
the rest of the way using the lazarus pit and then
he becomes red hood if you never watched it jensen
ackles actually played the character during the
under the red hood movie it's actually a pretty
great movie but it was done during the early 2000s
now jensen ackles is actually going to be on the
boys season three playing marvel's version of
captain america from the avengers it's sort of
like a parody version of captain america called
soldier boy he's giving off a very hydra cap vibe
so if you're big jensen ackles fan if you watched
any of his tv shows supernatural or anything like
that or batman under the red hood he's actually
going to be doing way more comic book stuff and
he's actually going to be playing their batman
during the long halloween movie they're actually
doing a two-part batman long halloween movie
the first part's going to be out pretty soon
the second part will be out a couple months later
this year so theoretically you could call him
like the fifth version of batman that we're gonna
see in the next two years they haven't said which
actor is going to be playing their version of the
joker here during this it seems like jason todd
is in gotham breaking into amusement mile working
some case by himself where he finds this jokerized
dead body and has then killed her almost killed
by the joker here or someone who's been jokerized
it's not totally clear if they're going to use
the lazarus pit explainer for how he comes back
or a similar twist or if he's just on the edge
of death and goes into a coma then comes out and
becomes red hood that way there's only going to
be about 10 episodes during season 3 so they're
probably going to speed run some of the parts
of this under the red hood storyline but this
is what his red hood costume looks like just like
comic book jason todd red hood he goes from being
a hardcore version of robin to full on using guns
killing criminals left and right without any kind
of mercy and just like in the under the red hood
storyline it seems like during the trailer footage
he's mostly targeting the mob the other really big
new character they're doing is scarecrow they were
hyping him up earlier last year but he's inside
arkham asylum here in the trailer where you see
him they're using him as kind of like a hannibal
lecter style character during season 3 where he's
an arkham for the most part and they go to him for
help on a case because he's an expert and it also
seems like someone might be using his fear toxin
whether or not he's actually connected to that or
vicious some other criminal who's stolen his fear
toxin and i believe that's what this yellow vial
is supposed to be where you see the person's eyes
dilate that may or may not be connected to the
jokerized victim that jason todd is investigating
an amusement mile just because of the way they cut
the footage like you see jason taught an amusement
mile with a jokerized person going straight to the
yellow vial of fear toxin but their version of
scarecrow on the show is being played by vincent
cartheiser who most of you probably remember
as pete from mad men bit of a jump for him so
it'll be interesting to see what he does with the
character then we finally have a new live-action
version of barbara gordon it's been a hot minute
since we've seen live action barbara gordon i'm
sure zack snyder had continued with his justice
league sequels we would have seen a version of
her in the background and if you actually saw my
video on the plots for justice league 2 in justice
league three we learned what the story of the
entire justice league snyder cut trilogy was going
to be so we'll have a link for that video down
in the description but at the end of that story
like the very end of justice league three the end
of the trilogy we were gonna flash forward to the
future and we would see a version of commissioner
gordon but it would be commissioner barbara gordon
they're kind of doing that with this version of
the character during titan season three she'll
be commissioner barbara gordon just like on batman
beyond but as you can see she's actually a pretty
young version of the character and she's in the
wheelchair so it's sort of like post-killing
joke barbara gordon batgirl and she's kind of
transitioned to more of an oracle type of role
because of the way they treated batman during
season one and season two we might also see
some batgirl flashbacks like it would be weird for
them to do batgirl and not actually do batgirl it
seems like just based on this actress's age it's
only been about 10 years or so since the events
of their killing jokes since she was batgirl
they haven't said much about what nightwing's
relationship with this tv show version of batgirl
is either if they had a romance in the past or if
they have some romance in present day but if
you didn't watch titan season 2 at the end
of that in sort of a post-credit scene the end
credits starfire sister blackfire shows up who's
come to earth to kill her because she wants to
thrown up tamarind their homeworld starfire has
a stronger claim to the throne than she does and
even though starfire doesn't want anything to do
with her people she still wants to kill her to
prevent her from potentially threatening her
for the most part i think that blackfyre is
supposed to be the season 3 villain and there
is a lot of footage of raven walking around with
her on set with raven's new costume even though it
hasn't been that long since the show started the
actress who played her looks like she's so much
older now it's sort of like millie bobby brown
and the kids from stranger things like you start
the show when they're really young and even though
it's only been a couple years since they started
the show they all look way older now but the idea
now is that raven has fully come into her power so
she's way more powerful during season three than
she was during season two pretty much all the rest
of the characters are back and i believe they're
also bringing donna troy back who they killed
off in the season 2 finale but if you haven't
read any of the teen titans comics donna troy
is famous for resurrection in coming back from
the dead there was a whole saga about her true
identity called who is donna troy because she had
this really confusing backstory that didn't make a
whole lot of sense because so many different comic
book writers had done different things with the
character across the eras so during the modern age
they tried to bring a lot of that into continuity
and simplify a lot of that backstory so either
they're bringing her back in flashbacks during
season two then maybe bringing her back to life
or they just bring her back to life and everyone's
like wtf just happened where'd you come from
superboy and crypto are back the actor who placed
him also bolt way up he's the connor kent version
of superboy the clone so obviously his powers are
a little bit different from say like jonathan kent
superboy they're doing more of a jonathan kent
twist on superboy on the superman and lois tv show
where even though they're doing the twins like
it's a very different twist on the superman mythos
you have twin boys you have jonathan ken who seems
like he doesn't have powers at least for now in
jordan kent who's actually named after jorel like
that's where the jor in jordan comes from but
it's his powers who manifests first and he's
kind of like the edgier version of the character
you're kind of wondering if he might break bad at
some point whereas some of conor kent's powers
are a little bit different like he's not quite
as powerful as superman he has a lot of the same
basic powers he can't fly but he's also not quite
as weak to kryptonite as superman is because
he has 50 human dna that comes from lex luthor
there isn't supposed to be any kind of special
air verse crossover with titans or anything like
that this year they did mention roy harper a lot
during season two so i'm assuming that if they
get a season four or season five they'll probably
do a version of roy harper at some point to pay
that off and probably a speedster like wally
west because he's a big titans character but
the show starting in august on hbo max they said
they're gonna release the first three episodes on
day one and then the rest of the episodes once
per week i believe there's ten episodes total
they did the same thing with the boys season
two episodes like releasing a couple episodes
on day one then everything else weekly i will be
doing videos for all that stuff there's a lot of
big comic book stuff happening this summer
and later this year speaking of superman 2
i've got a new witcher season 2 trailer video
with henry cavill that i'll post later tonight
my full loki episode 3 video will post next week
and rick and morty season 5 episodes are starting
on sunday so my rick and morty season 5 episode
1 video will post monday morning so happy summer
everyone there's going to be a whole bunch of
big stuff coming up in the next couple of weeks
everyone click here for my full loki episode
2 video and click here for my loki episode
3 trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!